today on the matte wall show horrific
photographic evidence suggests that a
prominent abortion clinic in dc is
killing babies after they're born but
the d.c government is running cover for
the clinic and refusing to investigate
we'll discuss also elon musk buys a big
stake in twitter and liberal female
journalists cry about being traumatized
by mean comments on the internet the
daily wire gets a mention on snl and
brian stelter on cnn shocks no one by
coming out in defense of child groomers
in our daily cancellation a conservative
pro-life website criticizes me for my dr
phil appearance why well i read the
article and i'm still not sure we'll
talk about that all of that and more
today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you might already be investing in
cryptocurrency but did you know that you
can trade bitcoin ethereum and over 80
other cryptocurrencies in a tax
advantaged ira with an alto crypto
crypto ira you can trade crypto like
bitcoin and avoid or defer the taxes
get into investing in crypto and do it
in a tax advantaged retirement account
altos crypto ira is the easy way to get
crypto into an ira trade all you want
without the tax headache create an
account in just a few minutes you can
invest with as little as 10 bucks no set
up charges very easy secure trading 24 7
through alt dose integration with
coinbase 80 plus coins available
including bitcoin ethereum and cardano
multiple ways to fund your account you
can make a cash contribution transfer
cash from an existing ira
or you could roll over an old 401 k open
an alto crypto ira account with just as
little as ten dollars just go to altoira
dot com slash matt that's
a-l-t-o-i-r-a dot com slash matt go to
alto ira.com matt
one of the consequences of spending time
on social media is that you're likely to
encounter without warning as you
mindlessly scroll along
images of violence and death it's always
unsettling to see such things of course
but it's all the more jarring and after
a while desensitizing to see them out of
nowhere sandwiched in between like a
news article about the grammys and a gif
of a cat or something
death becomes just another bit of
content in this context floating by on
the endless river of content early last
week we saw a prime example of this kind
of thing when footage of a
14 year old boy falling to his death
from an orlando theme park ride started
making the rounds a terrible tragedy i
happened to cross the video
without knowing what it was or why it
was posted and like millions of other
people i watched the boy fall heard his
body hit the ground
something that none of us needed to see
or should have seen
but we saw it
um on friday
many of us were again confronted with
images that we did not bargain for
even amid all the brutality and despair
casually posted to social media
platforms every day
these stood out they are in fact the
worst things i think i've ever seen i
wish i hadn't seen them
yet in this case they are images that we
actually should see as much as we might
be haunted and sickened by them lila
rose president of the pro-life
organization live action posted photos
of five unborn children who had been
aborted in dc
in an abortion clinic operated by doctor
quote unquote cesar santangelo
the bodies of the victims were obtained
by a group called progressive
anti-abortion uprising which is a
pro-life activist group
who report that they obtained them from
a whistleblower inside the clinic
and they then contacted the dc homicide
unit about the bodies
now according to this group and sources
who spoke to live action
at least some of these children may have
been aborted after they were born
infanticide or may have been subjected
to an illegal partial birth abortion
here's more from live action it says
physician experts have told live action
news that five aborted children in a dc
apartment appeared to have been viable
human beings raising questions about
potential legal and serious ethical
violations by the abortion clinic dr
robin perrucci a neonatal specialist
told live action news i can say with
confidence that these babies died at an
age when they were viable premature
people
in her friday morning comments she noted
that she was going to work in a nicu
where she would quote care for little
ones this size and age
now all you have to do is look at the
images which i'm not going to show you
here but you can easily find them
and you can see that these were fully
formed infant children
the very advanced
stage of development as well as the the
injuries you can visibly see on their
bodies
along with the report from the clinic
whistleblower
all lend credence to the claim that a
federal crime was committed
this looks like gosnell all over again
gosnell 2.0
and as with gosnell who was able to
operate his house of horrors in
philadelphia for decades without
consequence
i mean in his case that literally blood
smattered smeared on the walls
dead bodies in in refrigerators and that
sort of thing just an absolute
horror show
and it was like that for decades in the
middle of a major american city
city officials had little interest in
getting involved and the same thing is
happening here the washington post
reports this morning the city medical
examiner does not plan at this time to
perform autopsies on the five
quote-unquote fetuses police removed
from a capitol hill row house earlier
this week according to two dc officials
with knowledge of the case even though
the group involved in their discovery
claims that the fetuses were all
late-term abortions performed illegally
not going to perform an autopsy
now put aside for a moment the nature of
the injuries
uh the report from the whistleblower the
stage of fetal development all of that
aside
wouldn't the simple fact that you were
given five dead bodies five dead and
mutilated bodies wouldn't that be enough
reason to warrant an autopsy
i mean
somebody calls you up and gives you a
tip and says we've got five dead bodies
here
and you come and claim them
aren't you wondering how they died
how would you not perform an autopsy
wouldn't that be the first thing you do
shouldn't law enforcement officials be
curious about how these children died
do taxpayers in dc not pay the salary of
the city medical examiner precisely for
cases like this cases where people are
dead and it's not clear how they died
the police announced mere moments after
discovering the bodies they held a press
conference and they said there's no
reason to think that an illegal abortion
occurred
but how could they possibly know that
just by looking
what's going on here
well what's going on is that the wagons
are circling the abortion industry is
funded and protected by the government
to such an extent that the abortion
industry is basically its own
quasi-governmental agency at this point
when the center for medical progress
conducted an undercover investigation of
planned parenthood a few years ago and
exposed on video
unequivocally that the organization is
harvesting organs and selling body parts
and this was proven
you have planned parenthood officials on
video admitting it
what happened then the cops raided the
journalists who revealed these crimes
they're the ones who were threatened
with prison time
the organization who committed the
crimes suffered no consequences at all
didn't even get their funding cut off
by the way
didn't even get their their federal
funding cut off even after republicans
took control of the government
it was after this that we had a
republican president and republican
congress and they just kept sending that
money to planned parenthood
the government protects its own
the abortion industry is its own
now i asked rhetorically why the medical
examiner is not interested to find out
how these people died
the answer of course is that the
authorities do not recognize the people
as people
and that's really what makes these
images and this story so important you
know most of the conversation around
this story will be about whether those
children were victims of illegal
abortions or post-birth abortions
um
but but we have to realize it's also
quite possible they were not late term
abortion that is the killing of fully
developed
viable infants who can easily survive
outside the womb
that is legal in dc
the clinic where these murders occurred
boasts that it will kill babies at 27
weeks or later
again these are babies who just give
birth to them and they can survive
they'll need a little bit of medical
attention
um i mean every actually in fact every
newborn who was born needs attention
and it's no different for a baby born at
27 28 29 30 weeks
but these are not blobs of cells they're
babies
if you've seen a newborn
you have seen a maybe slightly bigger
version of what a baby killed during
late term abortion looks like
that's why the images are important
i think we would make a mistake in
focusing too much on the question of
whether they were aborted illegally or
not that's an important question
and if a crime occurred then those
responsible should go to prison but the
greater point here is that it's quite
possible and common to murder an infant
crush his skull dismember him
without committing any crime at all
according to the laws on the books
the pro-abortion movement they would
like you to believe
if you if you happen across these images
they prefer if you don't see them at all
but if you do they would like you to
believe that the images
of these mangled and bloodied infants
are anomalous they're an exception
they are in fact something other than
abortion
that's a lie
this is what abortion is
if you support abortion
this is what you support
thousands of babies who look just like
this who who look like infants who are
infants not fetuses
are butchered every year in this country
this is what it comes down to
you know if you've again if you've ever
seen a newborn baby which i'm sure you
have
if you support abortion you support
dismembering that baby
and throwing him into a dumpster because
that's what abortions do abortion
clinics do
now you could put every other issue and
debate aside and boil it down to this
one side of the ideological divide
believes that it is good
to dismember infants
they also believe that it's good to
castrate children should any children
survive the womb
this is really all you need to know
that should be enough i think to make
your judgment about who the bad guys are
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know of course there are many many
leftists out there just begging to be
cancelled
and i always enjoy canceling i'm gonna
give them a little break just for right
now because i have a way bigger
cancellation to make and that is
store-bought meat yes you heard me it's
not a it's not a person we hope the meat
is not a person but it's sold to you but
who knows you know really for some of
this meat that you get it's sold to you
by people who do not care about you or
your health they hide behind the smoke
and mirrors of empty labels like all
natural cruelty free grass-fed whatever
any of that's really supposed to mean
that's why i'm giving all of you my
sweet sweet babies a chance to prove
your loyalty follow me on this righteous
crusade to cancel store bought me stop
buying it instead do yourself your
family and the world a favor and start
purchasing your meat from good ranchers
why well not only is good ranchers the
exclusive meat company of the daily wire
it's actually 100 born raised and
harvested in the usa that can't be said
for 85 percent of the grass-fed beef in
stores that claims to be from the usa
but actually it isn't so my point is
you're being lied to by big meat but
good ranchers is here to tell you and
tell it to you straight their meat is
steak house quality locally sourced in
america affordable it's shipped straight
to your door and it's absolutely
delicious i can tell you from experience
it's time to cancel store-bought meat
and i'm ordering you to join me in doing
so so head to goodranchers.com walter
use codewall should check out to get 30
off the most convenient and delicious
purchase you've ever made go to
goodranchers.com walls today so that we
can all say goodbye to store-bought meat
once and for all
all right let's start um
a little bit of good news for a change
this is from the daily wire it says
tesla ceo elon musk has become left-wing
social media platform twitter's largest
shareholder taking 9.2 percent stake in
uh in the company
musk now has four times as many shares
as twitter founder jack dorsey who owns
just 2.25
bloomberg reported twitter shares surged
about 26 percent of pre-market trading
after the regulator filing release
monday detailing musk buying the holding
the stake is worth about about 3 billion
based on friday's market close
um the move comes after musk teased to
shake up at twitter or possible plans to
build a new social media platform that
promotes free speech he started talking
a few weeks ago about well he's been
talking for a while about it but
especially a few weeks ago about free
speech and twitter he put a survey out
asking his followers do they think that
that twitter protects free speech of
course the answer is no i think it was
like 70 percent of people said no
and then musk said well i'm going to do
something about this and then today we
find out what it is he just bought nine
percent of the company it really is uh
it really is incredible this and this is
exactly what we
we need somebody
with that much money and that much power
doing this now when i heard that elon
musk was talking about making a
competitor platform to twitter
um
that
would be better than nothing
but it's not nearly as effective as what
he's doing now
you know if you want if you actually
this is what i've been saying all along
about all these uh
these social media competitors whether
it's parlor or getter or you know gab or
delay trump's social media platform
which is by the way is a total
embarrassing failure he doesn't even use
it himself which is why i said a lot of
you people called me naysayers
yes you people
for criticizing me um
i was accused of being a naysayer when
we when we heard about trump planning
his own social media platform and i i
said it's gonna like fizzle out right
away that's exactly what happened he
doesn't even use it
um because there are a lot of reasons
for it
as i've been saying all along if you're
gonna do the competitor platform
to twitter then you can't just make
another version of twitter you have to
there's to be some kind of innovation
you have to give people a reason to use
this instead
but if what you have made is just an
off-market off-brand generic twitter
there's no reason for anyone use i'll
just use twitter in that case
um
but the other big thing is that to
compete this is the way it's
set up now if you want to compete with
twitter or facebook
um you're gonna need to have like tens
of billions of dollars to throw around
just to start
just to get on the map you need to have
tens of billions
to even have a chance to compete with
these platforms
and if you don't have that kind of money
to throw around it's it's um
it's
there's certainly no chance that you're
gonna make a dent in uh you might be
able to
make a little niche for yourself but
you're not gonna be able to make a dent
in facebook twitter tick tock
i think the better strategy is what musk
is doing is you know what i'm gonna
they've already got this thing set up
they have the platform
um the hundreds of billions of dollars
in development have already been poured
into it so now i'm just gonna take it
over
much better strategy
and um
there may be hope for us yet for some of
us on the on on twitter
i kind of assumed i i gave myself you
know babylon b's already gone i gave
myself maybe six to eight months of life
left on twitter before they finally
throw the axe down
um
who knows
we may live longer than that now with
elon musk taking over this from the
post-millennial says accused cry bully
taylor lorenz said she has suffered
severe ptsd from being a journalist
and broke down in an msnbc interview on
friday on friday's meet the press daily
show on msnbc host chuck todd briefly
discussed government statistics about
online harassment in women before
turning it over to correspondent morgan
radford who uh did a an interview
with washington post columnist lorenz
who covers technology and online culture
so let's let's begin first with the
setup from chuck todd
talking about this uh problem of online
harassment and he says that it's a it's
a problem that
especially impacts women and especially
female journalists they're the victims
of this let's listen to that
welcome back this week the white house
proclaimed april as national sexual
assault awareness and prevention month
one of the fastest growing threats to
women is online harassment the latest
government statistics show one in three
women under the age of 35 have
experienced
a type of essentially sexual harassment
online it's often underreported and many
times not taken seriously despite its
serious risk to mental health and
physical safety the administration is
now committed to a new global
partnership for action on gender-based
online harassment and abuse the goal
deliver an action plan and combating
technology facilitated gender-based
violence by the end of this year morgan
radford joins me now she's been doing
some reporting on the impact of this
type of harassment especially
uh the impact it has on women in
journalism and it's not even a close
call morgan as nasty as the attacks can
be on on on some of us in this business
if you're a woman it is at another level
that's right chuck and you know before
this was all sort of anecdotal but now
we have hard data i mean this is one of
the biggest issues facing female
journalists right now
well
we'll get to the um
the actual example because they do bring
in in fairness
they bring in
because if you're skeptical
well they have us they have a victim
story that they share with us
but i actually think that chuck todd
understates the problem to begin with
because he says that one in three women
under the age of 35
experience online harassment well
it's actually three in three women under
the age of 35 and uh three and three
women of any age who have been online
for more than 30 seconds have been
harassed but the other thing is that
that's also true for men like literally
anyone who has spent more than half an
hour on the internet at any point in
their life their lives
has been harassed
it comes with the territory we all
experience it every single one of us
and the the larger of a platform you
have
the more people you're interacting with
um
the more people who know that you exist
the more the more that you're going to
be harassed
it's not a good thing i don't like it i
don't enjoy it
um i experience it all the time
you could just sift through my
email inbox
messages comments it's it's all there
so this is this is part of the terror
this is this comes with the territory
with the internet
is it good no it's not good
um
but we can't even begin to have any
serious conversation about this issue
however serious the issue actually is
but we can't begin to really talk about
it if you're determined to talk about it
through the lens of identity politics
and left-wing victimology 101.
if that's how you want to talk about
them we're not going to be able to have
any serious conversation
as evidenced by
taylor lorenz again washington post's
columnist and she she came on to talk
about her experiences by the way she's
also not under the age of 35 i think
she's in like her 40s and so this is the
example they give us for some reason and
here she is um talking about the trauma
that she suffered because of online
harassment listen
hey nice job on that story you soulless
effing
then also you'll see there's these
there's many people that are tweeting um
you know here's these are taylor
lorenz's loved ones they have photos wow
these are all photos of your family
members yeah children yeah they'll
threaten children they'll threaten my
parents i've had to remove every
single social tie i had severe ptsd from
this i i contemplated suicide it got
really bad
you feel like any little piece of
information
that gets out on you will be used by the
worst people on the internet to destroy
your life
and it's
so isolating
and terrifying
it's horrifying
i'm so sorry
it's overwhelming it's really hard
just put your phone down lady just put
your phone down go do something else
with you if you can't handle it then do
something else with your life
you're traumatized by your ptsd
i mean there there are people who go
overseas they're in they're in uh you
know armed conflicts they go to war they
come from war and they're not reacting
the way that you are
and even if they do you're putting
yourself when you use a phrase when you
use a term like ptsd you have
post-traumatic stress disorder
you are putting yourself on the same
plane
as um
people who watch their friends get get
uh blown to pieces on the battlefield
you're putting yourself in the same
conversation on the same level you do
not have ptsd no you don't
i'm not your psychiatrist i'm not your
therapist i haven't run any any tests at
all on you i've and yet and yet yes i
can sit here from a distance and say you
do not have ptsd
you just need to grow up
this is weakness
you're weak
you need to be stronger
or find another line of work
i mean that's the example that she gives
us is someone says uh uh oh you you
soulless c word
i get that ev that's like
600 times a day those sorts of comments
and that's the that's the best you could
do
that's the worst example you can give us
now bringing your family into it all
that kind of stuff that's terrible
that's absolutely terrible it shouldn't
happen
but it happens to all of us happens to
me i hate it i don't like it
it does that makes me angry once you
bring my my kids and my family into it
but um
we all experience it
without a doubt
there is it is it is true now so there
are two things to establish here
actually there are three because the
first thing we should point out maybe
the most important thing about taylor
lorenz
is that she is guilty of this kind of
thing herself this is what makes it all
the more ironic and ridiculous to bring
her on to talk about it she is one of
the
um architects of cancel culture
she has she's one of these quote-unquote
journalists who's whipped up mobs
against people try to get them canceled
try to get them harassed
trying to foment exactly the kind of
outrage against other people that she
says traumatizes her
and how much worse does that make you it
seems like you are actually kind of
soulless
if you're traumatized by being insulted
by people and yet and so you consider it
to be a traumatizing event and yet you
try to put other people in that position
that just makes you a horrible person
so that's one thing we have to establish
we also have to establish that a lot of
this is it does fall into the category
of just suck it up buttercup and deal
with it
because if you if you have to have to
make a choice
you know anyone with a with a platform
you didn't get it by accident
i know this from experience you have to
work
some some of us harder than others but
you still have to work and actually try
to build a platform
the kind of platform where they even
where they're even asking you to come on
cable news and talk about your
experiences
so a lot of effort went into that
and if you're going to make that effort
then you have to be prepared to deal
with the criticism
and because we live in the modern age we
live in the age of the internet
it's going to be a whole lot of
criticism
and a lot of it's going to be quite
vulgar and maybe a little bit upsetting
but if you can't deal with that then you
can't deal with being a journalist and
you need to find a different line of
work
because the here's the one advantage
this is the great thing
as rough as it as as rough and tumble as
it can get on the internet
the great thing is that it still exists
in your phone
and so you can always just put down your
phone
and live your life
and there's a lot of power in that too
you know i've i've noticed that i feel
that sometimes when um
when the mob's coming after me and
everybody's really upset about something
that i said and you know i'm getting
thousands of people
coming after me it actually is quite
satisfying that i can just
put my phone down and go fishing or
something
there's all these people out there on
the internet who are so mad and say i
don't even know it i'm not even reading
it
so you have that ability
and then the third point
is that it is also true
that the internet
the anonymity that comes with the
internet
it gives people
they feel licensed
to say the kinds of things that they
would never say to you in person
um
i mean i could say that again there's
something again i could say from
experience that
i talk about all these all these things
people say to me
um i've never
encountered it in public
like
every day i could go online check my
inbox whatever look at the comments and
there's all these people saying ah
you're a piece of crap you're this and
that um
nobody has ever come up to me in public
and said that to my face ever not
once
so these are all a bunch of cowards for
the most part they hide behind the
anonymity and everything and uh the
internet enables people to do that
and so i think that there is a
conversation that we can have
um
about
why why is it that people act this way
to each other on the internet what does
it say about us
i know we like to think that uh well the
internet isn't the real world and so
it's a totally different thing
and you hear that all the time oh
twitter isn't the real world well yes it
is it's the real world because these are
actual human beings who are using this
communication
tool to speak to each other it's it's
the real world and whatever you say on
the internet that's you saying it
now you might want to if you're the kind
of if you are a troll if you're one of
these vicious trolls on the internet and
you say a lot of terrible things
uh you might want to comfort yourself by
telling yourself that's not really me
that's just internet me
that's the me and the youtube comments
i'm telling someone to kill themselves i
would never say that in real life well
you are saying it in real life this is
reality
so we could talk about that what is it
that drives people to behave that way
why does the anonymity bring this out of
people what does it say i mean all these
it's an interesting conversation
at least but we can't really have it
if we again insist on having it through
the lens
of identity politics
the left's uh victimhood hierarchy
because they don't even want to start
the conversation unless they can
establish at the outset
that their preferred victim groups are
the primary victims of this
thing
when in fact this is a ubiquitous
problem
that everybody on the internet
experiences
and if we're not going to acknowledge
that
from the outset of the conversation then
there's no point in having the
conversation
all right i'm staying in the realm of uh
cable news here elsewhere in cable news
brian stelter is taking on the
anti-grooming laws in florida no
surprise that this
perverted potato is in favor of grooming
children so he brought on another creep
by the name of charlotte climber who's a
male who identifies as a woman
and asked some real hard questions you
know this is what journalism is all
about folks listen to this
charlotte i think we should start with
the history of this there is an ugly
history in the united states of
portraying gays lesbians transgender
people
as perverts as predators who are preying
on children
and when i see some of the coverage in
the last week
seems to me they are just repeating an
ugly history
good morning brian yeah it's it's
exasperating
[Music]
always with the hard questions there
serving up the hard question right from
right from the beginning um but the
thing i really what it says on the
screen there it says lgbtq community
latest to be caught in culture war
now let's think about that for a second
the lgbt community is they're the latest
to be caught up in this culture war
and stelter obviously
begins this with
from a from a false premise that all of
the criticism on the right about the
grooming of children that it's really
targeted at lgbt people that's actually
not the case
what we're talking about specifically
when it comes to the florida law are
teachers
who want to use their position as
teachers to indoctrinate to sexually
indoctrinate children
and um there are plenty of heterosexual
teachers who are
radical leftists who do who do the same
thing
i don't care if they're lgbt if they're
straight doesn't matter
that makes no difference to me
the point is that i don't want you
sexually indoctrinating children
however you personally sexually identify
is irrelevant that's the point
leave it out of the conversation the
kids don't need to hear about that
uh so that's a false premise to begin
with and then another false premise that
says on the screen lgbt community latest
to be caught in culture war yeah i
wonder how this happened how did this
happen exactly the lgbt community
uh for
the last several decades has been
incessantly waging a culture war
and now they find themselves caught in a
culture war
how did that happen that's a mystery
activists who incessantly wage culture
war find themselves caught in a culture
war
funny how that works isn't it
uh next we got um
we'll go over to snl
and it's pretty maybe
every season of snl you get
if there's uh if there's however many
you know 20 cumulative hours of
programming probably more than that you
might get five minutes
of good content
and so this is part of the five minutes
and it just so happens that the daily
wire got a mention on snl over the
weekend so let's listen to that
the conservative media organization the
daily wire said they'll spend a hundred
million dollars to create children's
programming to counter woke media
companies programs will include clifford
the big straight dog
and kanto but in english
and one fish two fish that's how many
fish genders there are
i i gotta i saw that clip yesterday and
the wheels started turning because that
last idea is actually pretty good one
fish two fish that's how many fish
genders are actually like that idea i
might take that and and run with it
um
and you know it look the the daily wire
getting a mention on on
saturday live
what you have to understand is that um
they would much rather ignore us
so the fact that we get a mention at all
it means that they they can't ignore us
anymore because of what we're doing so
that's a that's a victory in and of
itself and it was actually it was a
pretty decent joke
i'll give him that
all right let's um move to this so we're
going to go back first to ancient
history
it could be hard to remember the things
that happened way back in the past but
if you can think back all the way
to last october october of 2021
here's what colin kaepernick
social justice activist here's what he
was saying back in october of 2021 so
this is like six months ago let's watch
this again
they don't want you to understand
is what's being established
is a power dynamic before they put you
on the field
teams poke
pride and examine you
searching for any defect that might
affect your performance no boundary
respected
no dignity left intact
[Music]
come on boy
look at that shape there look at this
mr farmer i got your bid 30. it's 30 to
you 100. so
next we're coming up best one we got
500
[Music]
look at this here
come on who wants this
700.
there we go now 1000
[Music]
yeah um it says october 2021 and the nfl
is slavery and these poor
helpless slaves in the nfl
who are paid 20 million contracts
but that
that doesn't matter
you know that's the fact that they're
being paid for their work to begin with
you would think already disqualifies
them from the status of slave if you are
volunteer first of all
even if you're not getting paid if
you're volunteering to do any kind of
job at all then
uh and you have your wits about you and
you can consent to to it
uh
then it's not slavery and then if you're
getting paid it's especially not slavery
and if you're getting paid 20 million a
year you would think it's it's as far
from slavery as you can actually get
it's actually the diametric opposite of
slavery if you've never heard of slavery
and somebody wanted to explain it to you
they could say look at an nfl player
it's the opposite of that is what
slavery is
uh but that's how colin kaepernick saw
it anyway as of six months ago now let's
fast forward to this weekend and here's
what colin kaepernick is saying now
we want to make sure that we come out we
show everyone i can still play still
throw it
and really just looking for an
opportunity opportunity for a door to
open
to have that be a pathway to be able to
get back in there get a starting job and
lead a team to a championship and that's
your message right there but if there's
an nfl scout any member of an nfl
organization watching you today what is
your message directly to them after the
years that you have been off the on the
off the field what is your message to
nfl teams
that i can help make you a better team i
can help you win games
this guy
yeah my message to nfl is look i'm a
good player i want to play for you and
uh i just want a chance to be a slave on
your plantation where my dignity will be
destroyed uh i'm i'm a great candidate
for this you could destroy my dignity
any time
i'd make a great slave
this guy is
i don't think it's an exaggeration to
say he's the most blatant
con artist
in modern american history i i can't
think of a
someone who would take that title from
him
and yet he's been incredibly successful
um
so he's at least that he's the most
blatant and most successful con artist
and modern american maybe in the history
of the world i don't know
the way that he's been able to profit
off of this racket off of this grift
while making no attempt to appear
sincere or consistent
it really is uh it really is incredible
and but it should go without saying that
um
look no nfl team is going to hire this
guy unless they're forced to so i'm not
going to say that no nfl team is going
to do it it's it is possible
i'd give it like a 40 chance actually
that he does end up on an nfl roster in
the next
potentially for this next season
but that's going to be because the nfl
you know the roger goodell and the suits
in the nfl basically force him on a team
no coach would actually choose to bring
this guy on he's 33 years old
32 or 33
hasn't played for six or seven years
he went one in ten his last season in
the in the league he was already on the
he had already hit his prime
and was descending into the
pits when he left the league six seven
years ago and he's not gonna be any
better now
and so you bring him on and you're
getting a guy who maybe is good enough
to be a backup maybe that's the most you
could possibly hope for
and in exchange for that you're getting
all of the publicity you're getting all
that and you're getting a guy who you
know ahead of time will accuse you of
racism
if you don't start him
even if you start a quarterback who's
also black you can start a quarterback
who's blacker than he is
and you're still going to be accused of
racism if you don't start him so you
know that ahead of time why would any
coach sign up for that
if they're forced to they will which
maybe they will be
let's get now to the comment section
[Music]
um let's see mike says matt i'm
disappointed that you completely ignored
april fool's day i guess i did uh but my
kids did not ignore it we put so this is
this was my kids my kids had an april
fool's joke and they were really excited
about this i got home from work
and as soon as i as soon as i walked in
the door they're they're like daddy
daddy you got to open the fridge the
milk has gone bad
and i was thinking like this is why why
are you
why do i why do i have to look at the
milk as soon as i walk in the door and
this is what they
showed me so it's the milk has gone bad
and it's
you get it because it's a
it's like the milk is gone he's got a
knife and he's got the ski mask and
everything
and they also put the sign there so in
case i didn't get the joke i think the
milk has gone bad oh no
that is
i gotta say that's top quality
dad humor and this is from
eight-year-olds
so they already
are getting the dad jokes down like that
so i was uh that was a that was a proud
papa moment um
let's see what else do we got uh
well we also have this by the way i got
to give a shout out to crane and company
they're the new sports uh show that we
just started a few weeks ago great show
by the way you got to go check them out
you download the podcast on apple
podcast and they're down in new orleans
for the final four and they happened
across a member of the sweet baby gang
who's uh walking around downtown new
orleans wearing the sweet baby gang
t-shirt
representing
just totally confusing everybody he
walks by now in new orleans you're used
to seeing a lot of weird things and
everything but um that
a bearded
man in a diaper is probably not
something that you see every day so
uh
shout out to the sweet baby gang there
all right let's see henry says
jada is a classic narcissist they like
to rub situations like sleeping with
others uh to their in the faces of their
spouses they have no remorse about doing
it
everything a narcissist does is right in
their mind even though it's bad to
normal people
uh yeah they think they're right yes but
to be more specific i think that as a
narcissist they believe that they are
more complex more interesting more sort
of nuanced
spirits than everybody else and so they
think that you know even if they do
something that's technically wrong
their reason they're just sort of so far
above the rest of us that uh they have
reasons that we can't understand and i
think that's kind of what you get with
jada smith
uh amanda says my three-year-old
announced this morning that she's a
kitty cat obviously she knows who she is
better than we do we're trying to figure
out if we need to call the vet first or
just go forward with getting her a
litter box and food bowl
you're joking but this is actually
happening in schools this is really 100
happening that there are
maybe not three-year-olds but
older than that you know kids in third
and fourth grade who identify as animals
and their teachers are supposed to treat
them as animals and respect that
self-identification that is a real thing
that is
a
relatively frequent occurrence in
schools these days
yet another um
milestone on the slippery slope that we
were told would never happen
it's
we were told for years it's completely
absurd it's offensive to even suggest
that if we respect people's quote
unquote gender identity eventually we're
gonna have to respect their species
identi identity
up until i don't know yesterday we were
told that uh uh no that's a that's a
that's transphobic come on that's
paranoid that's insane
that's a fallacy to argue that well it's
actually happening
um
lenny says
my problem with this show is that matt
spends hour upon hour complaining about
all the problems in society but never
offers a solution what's the point of
talking about this if you aren't going
to try to solve it
well first of all that isn't true i do
talk about solutions i actually try to
go out and implement my solutions too so
i don't just talk about them but putting
that aside
you know i actually believe that this
obsession and i hear this a lot from
people about oh why aren't you talking
about the solutions
this obsession with solutions
is sort of a cop-out
um this solution-oriented thing
like there's no point talking about or
thinking about anything if it can't
easily be fixed or solved
that's that's what you're saying
and so what you're really saying is
there's there's no value in simply
understanding
i disagree i think that there's
even if there's something going on if
there's a problem in society and we
can't immediately solve it
and if i notice a problem but i don't
have your five point plan
do this do this do this and we'll solve
it does that mean we should just ignore
it we shouldn't talk about no there's
there's a lot of value in understanding
in general value and understanding also
value and understanding the world you're
living in
you should want to understand things i
think this is also this is one of the
reasons why we're um
so death phobic in our culture
um
of course everybody
everyone's afraid of death to a certain
extent but we're afraid of thinking
about or talking about death
and then covert 19 comes along and
people lose their minds
and collapse into this state of paranoia
because they've never even thought about
the fact that they're mortal beings and
i think this this kind of ties into it
it's like well why
why think about our mortality why think
about death because we can't solve it
we're all going to die you can't do
anything about it you can you can delay
it for a while but not even that long
but you're still gonna be mortal you
can't solve death
yet another one of the uncomfortable
aspects of life that i don't have a five
point i don't even have a 20-point plan
to solve death um
and yet i still think we should confront
it and talk about it
so
that's the case for many things in our
culture and finally
matthew jordan says matt the answer we
all need is which fast food place has
the best french fries uh arby's has the
best french fries hands down no question
about it uh the worst are mcdonald's and
mcdonald's french fries have actually
gotten worse over time i think you know
kids these days don't realize 20 years
ago the mcdonald's fry was uh sufficient
at least it was it was adequate and now
it's they're like soggy and cold they
don't even put salt on them anymore
they're undercooked it's disgusting so
they're the worst most overrated are
chick-fil-a uh not bad
but not worth all the hype well i'm sure
you i know you all heard you heard about
on this show uh and many other shows as
well the leaked disney lgbt agenda last
week well the daily wire decided to
respond daily wire had a town hall
meeting where co-ceo got king jeremy
boring announced our 100 million dollar
investment into dw kids we're getting
involved in kids entertainment because i
can tell you parents like myself are
tired of the fact that you just you
can't
you basically cannot trust any kids show
anymore uh and every day it's an it's
another one bites the dust another one
that you thought was just innocent
family fun and you turn it on and you
see a drag queen or something like that
that's why we're getting involved we've
hired the veggie tales writers to help
create our first two children shows
that's uh first one is chillatime about
a family of homeschooled chinchillas and
doodles with noodles that centers on a
man and his puppet giving drawing
lessons over the next three years we've
committed to investing 100 million
dollars into children's entertainment
content because in order to change the
culture you have to make the culture and
daily wire is making the culture but the
thing is we need your help to do it so
head to dailywire.com subscribe and use
code build the future for 45 off your
membership right now now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
so i'm going to respond to something
that perhaps on its own is not worth a
response but it represents a larger
trend and it's it's that larger trend
that concerns me so
one thing i've noticed over the past uh
several years but especially the past
several months is that there's a certain
segment of the right
that somehow can't handle winning or
maybe they don't want to win or perhaps
they're envious that they're not the
ones personally achieving these
victories like they don't want to win if
they won't get special credit for it
whatever it is um whenever we here at
the daily wire have success with
something there are those on the right
who seem utterly determined to find
fault with it
often these are critics who never do
anything of note themselves never land
any significant blows in the culture war
never move the needle at all never put
anything on the line instead they
relegate themselves to the sidelines
while pointing out every perceived flaw
in those who are actually down in the
arena fighting the battles
as teddy roosevelt observed and his man
in the arena speech there are many who
confine themselves to criticism of the
way others do what they themselves dare
not even attempt
now
today i want to focus on just one
example of this kind of thing a
conservative ostensibly on my side who
seems absolutely desperate to criticize
what most on our side would consider to
be a big win
so the website lifesitenews which is a
pro-life news organization that i have
vocally supported amplified many times
over the years i appreciate their
journalism they just publish an article
written by um a guy named nick bell with
this headline
matt walsh's debate with transgender
activists on dr phil show left a lot to
be desired
now this is far from the first time i've
encountered criticism from the right for
my dr phil appearance you know i flew
out to los angeles to appear on
mainstream television in front of a
hostile audience on a panel where i was
out number three to one it was a risk
because i knew that if i choked or
floundered it would be an embarrassment
that potentially my career may never
fully recover from but fortunately the
embarrassment was all on the other side
of the debate a debate that's been
viewed many millions of times it
represents i think
one of the first times that some of
these basic arguments against trans
ideology have been presented to a
mainstream audience um so that's all
it's all good you know you'd think but
that's not enough for the nick bells of
the world my appearance left a lot to be
desired he says he sits back reflecting
two months after the fact that has
decided that my efforts were simply not
good enough yes you took on three gender
ideologues on national television and
humiliated them he mutters from the
bleachers but could you have done more
and could you have done it better
now i'm not look i'm not taking issue
with the general concept of criticism
i'm not saying that other people on the
right should refrain from criticizing me
or the daily wire anybody else for the
sake of being a team player or whatever
criticism from an ally
can be good and valuable we need to be
able to do that
but when that criticism is petty and
irrelevant and weird and desperate
as it so often is
you begin to suspect that there's some
other motivation lying under the surface
and i do have that suspicion about this
article
as the author belt seems to spend most
of the essay grasping around in the dark
for something to criticize he begins
with this odd paragraph he says quote
the two non-binary guests seem to be
likable enough one is a woman who
believes she's a man and has long hair
and a beard the other is a man who has
successfully blended the characteristics
of both genders to create an appealing
hybrid they come across as well-meaning
people who have suffered due to people
misunderstanding their struggles in that
context simply using their preferred
pronoun seems a small ask
now for the record not to split beard
hairs here but the one with the beard is
a man the other is a woman
i wouldn't call either hybrid
appealing personally
and i definitely don't think my
opponents on stage were well-meaning or
kind or likable or anything like that
and it is indeed a big ask that i should
deny reality for their sake
now he goes on in circuitous fashion
circling around whatever point he seems
to want to make he seems to think that i
was caught up too much in semantics by
focusing on the definition of a woman
rather than the more important issues he
then makes this really bizarre claim he
says that conservatives must quote make
the case that transgenderism inflicts
unacceptable damage not only of those
who dissent from it but also on the
transgenders themselves as well as
children caught up in a social contagion
much of walsh's appearance on dr phil
exemplified the predicament of
conservatives when they forfeit this
crucial piece of their argument
well what
how did i forfeit the claim that
transgenderism hurts kids
i specifically make that point during
the episode i make that point all the
time you'd be hard-pressed to find
anyone in media anywhere who makes that
point more often than i do
um things get stranger from here bell
writes quote walsh went on to bring up
the destruction of women's sports the
dangers of allowing men into women's
bathrooms as other reasons to oppose the
transgender agenda he mentioned the rape
at loudoun county virginia of a girl by
a boy dressed in a skirt this past year
that occurred in a women's bathroom
but the left-wing professor easily fends
walsh off by saying that she does not
support open bathrooms where anyone can
go in showing how easily the left can
neutralize the dangerous bathroom
argument by simply taking a compromised
position in this case separate bathrooms
for the transgendered that allows them
to avoid truly justifying the
transgender position
the thing is that's not the position
that the professor took in the episode
she absolutely did not endorse separate
bathrooms for transgender people
no leftist endorses that position
that that doesn't exist on the left it
can't
they want men in the women's room
nothing less than that
they're not going to take like a third
bathroom for trans people
no i i don't want that compromise either
because i don't see why we should make
any special accommodations for people
who are you know confused about their
gender just use the bathroom in
accordance with your biological sex but
but but the left they don't want that
compromise either because to do that
admits
that these are that you know the trans
the quote-unquote trans woman is not
really a woman and they can't admit that
so that's why it's a very good thing for
us to
you know talk about this on a national
on on a national stage specifically the
bathroom issue
we want to corner them into trying to
defend it
because it's a it's a perverse and
insane case they're making
the more they talk about it the better
it is for us
so yeah if you if you are on a stage in
front of a lot of people talking about
this issue
you shouldn't be talking about bathrooms
the entire time
but that should definitely be a feature
of your argument
so because you want to force them to
confront that force them in front of all
these people to say
that they want
men in the women's room and the women
who are uncomfortable with it it's
that's too bad for them
so what exact point does the author have
to make that's so important he felt the
need to say it two months later well
as best as i could tell his primary
contention is this which he states early
in his piece
isn't it a bit hair splitting to insist
on perfect logical rigor if the
alternative would lead to transgender
people feeling dramatically less mental
anguish
would that alternative lead to less
suicide would it allow the transgenders
to lead happier lives
later concluding his thoughts he follows
up on the same theme he says instead the
right should focus on the fact that the
very thing these confused people are
seeking their happiness will be harder
and harder to find the further they go
down this road walsh gets closest to
this sort of argument when he briefly
takes exception to the transgender
agenda being foisted on kids but failed
to develop the argument as a result much
of its force was squandered this dynamic
is a microcosm for the state of the
debate writ large the right would be
better served by shifting the argument
from an exclusive focus on girls sports
and dangerous bathrooms to the
well-being of the gender confused and
the increased likelihood for confusion
among children
the argument for truth and honesty and
sex and gender is dramatically more
powerful when the true stakes of the
issue the happiness and wholeness of
real vulnerable people are at the
forefront
now you wonder if bell actually watched
the doctor phil appearance or if maybe
he spent the last two months trying to
find a reason to disprove of the
performance and couldn't find one
but he owed the editors an article so he
decided to pull this one out of his
drafts and submit it anyway
whatever twisted path led to this thing
being published the fact is that i do
not focus the debate exclusively on
sports and bathrooms uh i just don't do
that so what's the real problem here
a lot left to be desired what's left to
be desired exactly he devoted two
thousand words to the subject and i
still have no idea
he's also wrong this is the most
important thing lots of other
conservatives are wrong about this also
so um it's an important point
the primary focus
of our argument against gender ideology
should not be
the well-being or happiness of the
gender confused it also shouldn't be
protecting children
that shouldn't be the primary focus
that's not our first point
now these are obviously very very
important things and we should emphasize
them and fight for them
obviously
but the primary point in our argument
against gender ideology
is that
gender ideology itself is false and
incoherent
that's the main point if you make
something else your primary focus you're
surrendering the strongest argument
which is that the left's entire position
is insane garbled nonsensical hollow
it's wrong they're wrong simple as that
they are making claims that are wrong
the fact that the false claims harm
people is secondary because the reason
they harm people is that they are false
you can't argue for gender ideology's
harmfulness until you've established its
wrongness
that's what makes it harmful is that
it's wrong
if it were true
that you know a boy you know might be a
girl trapped inside of a boy's body and
that he
well if that's true then then who are we
to say it's harmful for him to go out
and pursue
his his true female identity
it's not true it's a lie
and that's why it's so harmful so you
have to start by establishing that it is
a lie that it's false
that's the point of the what is a woman
question it's not semantics it's crucial
it's the core of our argument it is our
argument
so maybe i'm being hard on the author
maybe he's maybe he's sincerely just
confused about my strategy on dr phil my
my overall approach to this issue but it
does seem to fit into a pattern
of people on the right some people
noticing a victory on our side
and then laboring strenuously to
discredit it no matter how trivial or
trifling they have to be in their
efforts
we already know what teddy roosevelt had
to say about such people i'm not as
eloquent as him so instead i'll just say
to them uh you're canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vladovsky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
today on the ben shapiro show putin's
troops in russia allegedly massacre
hundreds and leave them in mass graves
plus the left desperately tries to
pretend the right is the aggressor in
our culture wars yeah that's not true
that's today on the benchpro show give
it a listen